[Music]
what's up GQ I'm ASAP ferg and this is
my centuries neither is known for having
great technology when it comes to like
running this stuff
I love these cuz you don't have to use
shoelaces in these and you could just
kind of slip these on I wear them
without socks because it's like you
could feel the breeze through the
materials the colors is fire and they
never get dirty I don't look like they
never get dirty I run I guess I'm not
running enough and they're dope but you
can flex while you're running
I'm pretty sure it's like a collab of
some sort a dude sends me like all of
the latest collabs
whoever did these is amazing thank you
sometimes I can't travel with this limit
on jury box because they always think I
have a bomb in it when I'm going to like
different countries just what so dope
about it is like it has these things
like this way you go put your ring on it
and place it like that so you can hold
like ten rings right here and then you
have like these departments right here
you can like put like a watches inside
of it like if you don't want it to get
scratched up this is like a velvet kind
of material so you know you can like put
your watches inside of it
in the hole is like a lot of juries just
got a lot of gold and stuff and then
this right here we go hold your earrings
and size it like these little holes
right place your hands inside like that
just like energy stuff I guess if you
have enough money to like afford this
then obviously you have some precious
goods that you don't want to lose so
they create luxury things that hold you
over
louboutin if you haven't seen my jury
you could check it out right here the
teeth is baguettes you know it's like
bigger stones or not at the eyes oh also
about this jury box it's a lot of things
out there so we have a little lock right
here what a key so this right here is my
Louboutin tall tree bag so it's like I
have the matching set I have the torch
tree bag and I have the jury box it's
the traditional leave Vuitton
monogrammed print that's why I love it
because it just looks classic it's not
like extra art around it or anything
like that so I would never gotta stop
and I just used this to like carry like
my brush Silk City my pink lotion for my
hair my wave Greece 360 like little
lotions and stuff I try to keep the
light small lotions and stuff like when
I'm traveling because like I said they
like to hold me up and check my bags all
the time so I try to keep it like smell
good I'll just be taking like all of
their like hotels I'll be staying at if
you have like taupe lotions like facial
creams dental floss
I got Colonna hair but I'm not gonna let
you I know what kind of Cologne I use
that means that charge a kiss bags I
mean
[Music]
you just gotta like get that in there
you see that shining sometimes when I'm
in the airport
it'd be early in the morning so I gotta
make sure their hairs lays down with a
pink motion and all the visors right no
I'm saying cuz the airport is like a
club you don't see some females in there
you're gonna see some celebrities in
there it's just ain't the loud music
it's better than the club you can
actually hit people talk so you just got
to be right and bright that's why at Oh
treat bag is so important these are so
important right this is a Cartier
vintage bag I don't know what it was
useful whatever but I see little things
like this with zippers and stuff and I
think about grilles and the same thing
for this Gucci bag I guess it's like a
coin bag you put coins I don't carry
coins but I carry a lot of grills like I
like little fancy grow bags like luxury
things the whole luxury thing is I keep
like all my grows in these bags because
I'll lose girls all the time and I just
every time I lose it I just feel like
God don't want me to have them and I
think that like God just wants me to be
more responsible so I just make sure
that you like some grow bags to hold all
my girls in different people do my grows
but mostly we'll bling my friend he also
did like all of these bracelets right
here like these pink diamonds blue
stones chocolate rubies these are the
chocolate rubies right here Rose go I
got the I got the rubies on the side on
the fangs I got pink stones and they're
blue stones I got pearls on each tooth
right the left these are the hood popes
right here these are so fancy I don't
even wear them sometimes I just like
looking at them I wear these all the
time though like these is the diamond
grilles I lost my bottom that's why I
had
it acts like the bottom grills the
diamonds up top this is a white go at
the bottom they all white go like this
got the diamonds in that this one is
just plain white gold these are the
solid gold I got an extra solid gold top
mr. tops and then I got one that says
like ASAP ferg I got these for my
birthday he blessed me with these for my
birthday just say a cipher gonna got
diamonds on the side grow bags essential
[Music]
this right here is actually a Ralph
Lauren robe but I went and I got my name
and brought it in it the Ferg logo the
Empire and my manager is gonna kill me
because this was supposed to be his
Christmas gift I loved him so much I
brought him to Christmas gifts and I
didn't realize I blew him to Christmas
yet so I'm like you're not getting both
Christmas gifts I'm gonna keep this one
because this is fire very essential
[Music]
these are the Pharrell chanel collab
these are very essential because for
others the first artist to ever have a
collab which you know this is more than
just like a pair of shoes to me I look
at these and I just see like my seed
areas being broken and I'm seeing like
years and years of hard work to get to
this point of creating this shoe and
doing it your way doing that your colors
like these colors are amazing the till
the yellow the red all the primary
colors that blue the green at the bottom
the orange like piping the gold Chanel
inscription inside just amazing he has
his name on it
Pharrell Chanel it just just rings a
bell I really love these shoes some
people may think they other way they
look stupid but I love them like how can
you not love these colors and the design
of the shoe it's like a loafer but then
it's like psych
we're like slippers lying there like
weird slipper loafer very essential as
you can see I like very different things
this is one of the best gifts that ever
got in my life for my friend [ __ ] he's
an artist he does like a lot of abstract
work we might see is aren't in the
street you might go to one of his art
shows but a [ __ ] took a cause doll
collaboration causing in the club and he
brought all like five different stuffed
animals and made them one so like
originally like it supposed to be like
two eyes there's like three guys he
added an eyeball and then it's like Burt
is like the Cookie Monster it's like a
big bird it's like all of them Ernie
like Elmo all of them put together so I
think that's cool like I've never seen
I'm Sesame Street like this it's like a
Sesame Street alien in a way and I think
it's a vibe because I'm an alien
thank you
[Music]
so this is my Chanel wallet right here
it kind of got a little the whole
because it's like in and out of my
pocket all the time but when I first
laid my eyes on this thing it was like a
bright infrared and it just caught my
eyes is either this or yellow but the
yellow when I knew it it got too dirty
but on this is very essentially because
like I put like on my credit cards my
IDs and you know my Global Entry car
everything inside this wallet because if
I don't I will lose that [ __ ] and I
ain't Lucia I got like oh like hotel
cards what is it a PDA card at the
police joints you show yeah I got a PDA
card in here this is in case the police
shot a [ __ ] with me I got a I picked
their card that's like the fancy movie
theaters that serve you wine and [ __ ]
while you chilling yeah I got credit
cards and [ __ ] that's all the boring
[ __ ] cuz I have cards man
[Music]
[Applause]
you go places you like this so this
right here is a vintage Hermes scarf
which I didn't even wear and this is
very essential because I like it I can't
tell you my spot where I got it from but
it's a vintage spot that has like a lot
of luxury vintage goods for good prices
I got this Hermes scarf for $100 I had
to get it was a still that's why I
really don't know what I was going to
use it for like I just brought it
because that was like a still like in
the store I probably be like $1500 or
something I probably could use it for my
hair but then I got like do-rags and
stuff for the prank is just like waiting
around my neck all rocky probably will
see it when I use it as a babushka I
probably go flip this like somebody
probably buy a fine
I just like to have like nice things or
it's very inspiring
thank you
[Music]
I got this from my grandmom's because
she just had it on credit and I'm like
hold up you got this thing at cabinet
she had like a bunch of like sewing
goods and stuff ahead I'm like I need
that like money no better than that
let me get that this is an all-purpose
bag put your shoelaces you can put your
toothbrush you could put your do ERISA
here you can fit a brush in here you can
fit jury in here dope things to keep
things organized
I like when bucket hats but it's not
like any old book that this is like a
Prada bucket hat there's like 20 19 new
Prada all black vibes with a good
throwback logo on it like you see I got
the kangaroo right now but I can always
switch it up like this I might have to
switch it up cuz I might have like four
interviews on camera my hair long I
might be looking crazy I should need to
grow back so I throw the bucket on
that's what a lot of artists don't let
shot know I have you looking crazy
sometimes we just clean the face up but
the hairline be looking push it back
sometimes you gotta throw that hat on
and get low you would never know as long
as I keep the smile on in the bucket I'm
straight and like I said I don't do like
any old buckets my bucket is like very
exquisite I have a lot of taste so you
know I collect poochy buckets Emilio
Pucci Fendi Prada I have a huge Kengo
collection I just love buckets bucket
low like [ __ ] it though
[Music]
this is a dealer work outfit climate hat
as a 3m in the back so like if you're
running at night nobody hit you then I
got like adidas shirt that I run in as
well it keeps your body cool everything
is about keeping your body cool and then
like right after it drops right up
you need like drenched and they're like
two seconds you can try like brand new
it's easy to watch and never changes the
shape this is a dieter shorts right here
same thing keeps your legs cool it dries
up really easy if you're sweating what
you're supposed to do when you run this
is like a good workout of sensuous well
[ __ ] last up we have the iPhone and the
charger I'm horrible when it comes to
charges I lose so many charges every
time I go to the airport I buy a new one
but then it's like you get these like
that like charges from like these
African spots where they be selling
charges and t-shirts and socks and [ __ ]
and it's like them charges will [ __ ]
your phone up so you got to make sure
you get a real charger from the Apple
Store that's compatible with your phone
because I swear I run through like three
phones every year because like I got the
wrong charger like it might charge your
phone but then this [ __ ] my starts
working the some [ __ ] and when I say
your phone circuit is like you know our
girls workout booty like when you start
seeing it [ __ ] flickering like that I
just queen your screen it's flickering I
mean your phone is twerking it's closing
its nuts it's close to not working have
a charger with an extra cord extra long
cord so you can just like sit
comfortably places what I also need that
I don't have is like a portable charger
where it just like walk around
everywhere just touch a whole
oh yeah you definitely need sighs hello
this is all but I took this call for
free well that's it you got singing all
of my essentials this is a cipher and
I'm starting now
[Music]
[Laughter]